it has been a record-setting 2016 for
the david pakman show record youtube
subscribers record youtube views record
podcast downloads we are on more radio
and television stations than we've ever
been able to do so before to quote
george w bush uh record new paid
subscribers it has really been an
amazing year and i would love it if you
helped close out the year on a strong
and note as possible you may know that
membership is the number one funding
source for the show i'm not trying to
get people to make financially uh
endangering decisions if the normal
membership prices of six bucks a month
or sixty dollars for the year are just
too high for your budget payless we have
a coupon code which is i voted 17 i
voted 17 all one word all lower case you
can use that coupon code at david
pakman.com slash membership for any
membership monthly or yearly your yearly
membership goes down to just thirty-six
dollars if you use that code a monthly
membership gets down to just three
dollars and sixty cents if you use the i
voted 17 coupon code pat has now
purchased 1.2 million discounted
memberships i know you might say why not
just get 600,000 regular price
memberships it's just something about
using the coupon code that you love and
i'm gonna give them out to my 1.2
million closest friends and family
that's right you should see Pat's
facebook it's crazy uh it's it's just
amazing the number of people knocking
down knocking down his virtual door for
one of these discounted memberships up
please do sign up let's close out 2016
as strongly as ever we're going to need
a really strong 2017 to have the impact
that we want to have david pakman.com
slash membership coupon code i voted 17